all right so for those of you
the other nights i believe it was monday
night who watched my
psa for boyish men um it has since
gained
a little bit of traction i also posted
it on facebook and i think it's sitting
at about 1.5 million views got a stretch
to get into
obviously it picked up a little bit of
talk a little bit of
chatter a few haters which is okay
not like i'm not used to that i'm very
used to it but
i did want to clear a few things up
about that video and just expand on it a
little bit
because that's always important you
can't ever say
everything you want to say in 15 minutes
and i've heard a lot of comments on it
a lot of praise a lot of criticism so i
figured i'd just go
through some of them if y'all are ready
all right so first of all
the some of the the misperceptions and
misconceptions
about some of the things i said in that
video
that i want to go through real quick
first and foremost
okay i don't think all men
are trash and i also want to again
so why did she say all men are trash
today
this backpedaling is going to uh
increase
significantly it's almost as if it's
worse than the original piece
she doesn't know when to shut her mouth
i rate the distinction that i made
between boys and men there is a big
difference
between boys and men and i'm talking
about an age difference i'm talking
about a mentality difference
if you are a man and you watch that and
you thought that i was calling you trash
i will apologize for that because i
don't think all men are trash i don't
think any men
are trash at all i think that some boys
who think that they are men
have a tendency shall we say
in 2020 to not quite act the right way
i'm not saying that girls act the right
way mind you
okay this is an equal opportunity
situation here but i'm not a dude in
case you haven't noticed i don't
identify as a dude i'm not a dude
so for me to do a video about how crappy
women are in the dating scene
i really don't think i could offer you
that much knowledge on it because i've
never dated a girl
yet okay so i can't help you there
i'm not saying that girls are perfect
and men are awful or boys are awful i'm
not saying that never would say that i'm
sure that there are many horrible girls
out there that do many horrible things i
myself if not perfect
i acknowledge that i'm happy to
acknowledge it so
i wanted to clear that up men i don't
think you're trash i happen to quite
like men
and especially real men who act like men
and who treat so you can see that again
she's
pointing and sputtering the same that
she did in the first video
i only like real men if you don't comply
with my rules and regulations and agree
with me then you're a boy
so if you don't agree with tommy right
now fellas you're a boy that's basically
what she's saying here this is
you know this is how the how she's gonna
operate and i'm gonna get into that in a
little bit but i want to clear up
some other misperceptions about the
video things that maybe you guys were
confused about
so i can help you out it was not in any
way
shape or form about my ex-fiance
we already know that now so before we
continue on here with her playback
i just want to shed a little insight
onto who the
uh ex-fiancee is so i've paused that
let me remove from stream and
okay we've gotta go
stop screen and then we're gonna share
this one
application window boom share okay so we
don't need any audio for this so
um this is the fiance that uh
she ended it with uh brandon fick so
so you know who this guy is uh he's an
ex a professional soccer player
he's uh running for congress right now
he's got coin i don't know how rich he
is but
he's definitely not poor um
by estimation from what i saw he's
probably worth a couple million dollars
in and around what she's worth she's
she's not loaded by any stretch of the
imagination
she's probably worth a couple million
dollars okay um
obviously money's right for both of them
so it's not a problem but she ended the
engagement with this dude over here
uh i'm guessing he's probably got the
six sixes he's definitely he's
definitely taller than her so he's
i'm looking at a guy that's potentially
six foot tall he's fit you know probably
a six-pack abs six month out of
relationship blah blah blah
but when you start to like drill down
through what happened here with the two
of them
and i think it's revealed in this
article over here
said so lauren 27 at times said she's
not ready to settle down and after
disgust her feelings was fick and they
ended so she dumped him because she was
not ready to settle down
now the guy that dm me said she cheated
on this dude with a country music star
whether she did or she didn't i don't
know but this is what he's saying from
his first hand experience
she dumped him she's she just turned 28
by the way she's not 27 i think um
on her wiki page her birthday's in
august so she is in fact 28 so she's so
she's at the epiphany phase like she's
running down oh look she's got a wrist
tattoo that's like the first sign of
basic right there um
romantic relationship i think there was
a 50 000
ring oh here's uh dating a navy seal
before this guy
oh by the way let's see if we can find
out how this guy
reached out or is in one of these two
articles probably on this one then here
it is
so this guy's a beta this is why they
ended up
um wrapping up this relationship or why
she dumped him and
and ended the engagement um let me
show you where it is because apparently
he dm'd her or he tried to slide into
her dms
uh linkedin profile she said yes blah
blah blah
so fick wrote on instagram march that he
first sent her a direct message so
so this guy was an orbiter on her
instagram
slid into her dms uh urging her to stay
strong after she was criticized by glenn
beck i don't know what she was
criticized for but this is classic white
knighting
behavior okay uh i'm not doing this
broadcast to
like take down uh who she is or any of
those things
this is not designed as red meat this is
designed as a learning experience for
you guys so i want you to sit back relax
and just take a couple of notes here so
you can learn something about what
uh enlightenment having a red pill lens
gives you as a guy
uh but anyway so this guy slides into
her dms urging her to stay strong after
criticized by glenn beck as a white as
as a good white knight that he is he
swoops in to save the honor of milady
he also invited larry at that time to
dinner and she never responded now
had she now she had probably would have
seen it i would imagine this guy has a
blue check mark
uh what's his name brandon fick
let's take a quick look here uh
brandon i bet he's a blue checkmark guy
on instagram
okay
no he's actually got quite a small
following so he's not a blue checkmark
dude so it is entirely possible that
uh she might have missed it in her dms
because those things pop a lot easier
for these okay anyway so no
wrong one scroll back down over here
i promise you there's a point to all
this as we tie it all together
anyway so stay strong uh criticized
blame back uh fix said the two
eventually met in person nine months
later so nine months later
i guess there's some dm's back and forth
um made the most out of that chance
opportunity
and that's it the end of the article
what a terribly written article anyway
so
they get together um after he slides
into dms
uh white knighting they get engaged for
a couple years and then obviously she
doesn't have genuine burning desire for
him so
she calls off the engagement and let's
go back to
our little rant now
because this is all relevant to what's
going on here
uh chrome tab and
i said what i said oh hang on i gotta
add auto give me a second stop screen
share screen chrome tab
and share audio share okay you guys
should be able to hear this let me know
if the audio is not coming through
in the chat okay my ex fiance is a saint
my ex-fiance is a great individual a
great
so why did you call off the engagement
if he's such a great guy
i'll tell you why because she saw him as
a beta he probably over those couple
years went through a process of beta
tization through a thousand concessions
not not a big enough dude for he was not
the best that she could do
right he was not i mean we can go back
to the
instagram and and look at his but she's
got something like a million and a half
or two million
follows he's got 11 000 uh he's running
for congress
believe it or not this guy was not good
enough for tall handsome running for
congress ex
you know ex-professional athlete
probably fit as hell
didn't you know did not cut it for missy
over here
you